pour ou contre la burqa alors
j'accueille nos deux invités 1 ce soir
alors on à fatiha boyer merci fatiha
d'être là aussi présidente de
l'association ni [ __ ] ni soumises en
seine-maritime et vous êtes musulmane et
pour la burqa est bon je vois c'est
mélissa voilà merci d'être là en tout
cas merci beaucoup alors je vous le dis
ce débat bien sûr tout le monde en parle
et c'est vrai qu'avec cette résolution
de l'onu
on en parle encore plus alors pour ou
contre la burqa ou vous a demandé votre
avis alors vous vivez au quotidien avec
la burqa depuis maintenant deux ans et
ça on trouvera deux ans alors pourquoi
vous avez choisi déjà porté la burqa je
connais c'est un choix personnel
parce que je me suis prêt je me sentais
plus à l'aise plus à l'aise oui voilà
vous portiez seulement le voile avant
seulement le ballon est exactement et la
burqa vous dit elle me permet d'être moi
même
oui exactement j'avoue ça vous permet
aussi vous dites d' éviter le
harcèlement exactement d'accord alors
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
problèmes avec la police
si vous pouvez sortir comme ça
aujourd'hui sens je peux pas je me suis
fait arrêter un 30 x 30 x dont vous avez
payé 7 vous allez payer cette amende de
180 euros oui et quand on vous demande
de de montrer votre visage
qu'est ce que vous faites vous les
montrer qu'à des policiers oui mais il
faut qu'israël femme met donc vous
pouvez pas sortir de chez vous ben non
donc c'est quand même compliqué comme
vie compliquée et des fois que de fortes
quand je sors je ne porte pas ce rendez
vous pas personnel ou administratif
est ce que vous êtes heureuse comme ça
avec le niqab et c'est vrai ou est ce
qu'avant au portier que le voile vous
pouviez non mais avec une cape je me
sens plus à l'aise
d'accord alors qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ceux et celles qui disent que
c'est un acte de soumission
qu'est ce qu'on vous dit ben je dis que
non c'est pas vrai c'est un choix
personnel et
on y libre et scoop oui comprenez que le
port de la burqa bon même si maintenant
on s'est remis en cause par l'onu et
mais c'est interdit en france
est ce que vous comprenez ce se soit
interdite ou bien vous dit non je
comprends pas pourquoi
oui je comprends pas pourquoi parce que
c'est un choix personnel je suis libre
c'est ma liberté
vous vous dites quoi vous dites vous
fait de mal à personne bien sûr je fais
tellement de personnes je suis comme
vous je vais normal donc vous comprenez
pas que ce soit interdit c'est pas
normal
alors justement on va on va en parler
bien sûr avec fatiha boyer et donc je
voulais dit présidente de l'association
ni [ __ ] ni soumises a va nous donner
son avis dans un instant j'aimerais
d'abord faire un tour de table et que
vous vous réagissiez hashtag balances
ton post
alors eric naulleau vous êtes contre
d'abord il faut juste rappeler que
l'avis du conseil des droits de l'homme
de l'onu n'a aucune valeur contraignante
oui donc c'est pas ça qui va remettre en
cause la situation française
ensuite un deuxième point très important
c'est que le port de la burqa et du
niqab est pas interdit en tant que
signes ostentatoires de radicalité
il est interdit pour des raisons de
sécurité on estime qu'on doit avoir le
visage découvert dans l'espace public
d'ailleurs il ya eu un retournement on
l'a évoqué presse que la semaine
dernière
le braqueur multirécidiviste qu'elle
donne faillite a été pris sous une burqa
est dissimulé sous une burqa donc une
fois qu'on a dit ça on retombe sur le
problème philosophique a évoqué madame
c'est qu'est ce qu'on dit parce qu'il ya
des pays où c'est obligatoire ya une
police religieuse qui passe dans les
rues et qui oblige les femmes à arvert
de revêtir des costumes traditionnels et
islamique mais qu'est-ce qu'on répond à
une femme qui vous disent c'est mon
choix et à côté vous avez une femme qui
est par exemple les fashion victimes qui
arborent tous les modes vous lui dites
vous êtes une victime de la mode elle
vous dit non ses moi aussi
philosophiquement on n'a pas réussi
articulé de réponse à ça à faire une
réponse est on a trouvé un petit tour de
passe-passe en disant non c'est pour des
raisons de sécurité mais au fond sur une
base religieuse je pense que ce serait
très difficile d'interdire le niqab et
la burqa en france moi je le déplore
parce qu'à titre personnel
dans un monde idéal selon moi les femmes
et ré dévoilé bernard laporte est contre
oui je suis content de moi ça me gêne
parce que quand même quand je parle à
sedan par exemple je suis pas à l'aise
des choses comme elles sont voilà je la
vois pas
samuel s'intéresse à migennes et puis
vous savez pas comment vous comment
exactement vous positionner je comprends
tout à fait j'accepte totalement
indifférent surtout ses explications
mais qu'elle comprenne que moi ça me
gêne et puis je vais vous dire un gamin
qui sort de l'école de rugby par exemple
c'est votre fils alors il n'est que dans
l'école de rugby
je met en valeur une ville c'est avec
papa de l'est quand même pas d'école
d'origine mais si vous voulez vous
cherchez votre fils mais je sais pas
s'il est véritablement la maman ou pas
la marque de ce gars mais si je vous
vois pas et je me dira ce gamin mais tu
ta main mais je chante ou pas ouais mais
là tu retournes sur les questions de
sécurité et sur les questions mais on
est d'accord c'est pour ça que c'est
très très très content qu'on est
toujours je vous dis sincèrement c'est
pour cette raison comment je suis
content on est toujours il a raison avec
naulleau pour l'instant lice
voilà ce qui qui voilà ce qui ressort le
plus et ce pour des questions de
sécurité on l'a vu il a dit la semaine
dernière écrit douanes faillite voilà
qui s'est servi de ça aussi pour passer
incognito vous eric revel pourquoi vous
être contre moi je suis totalement
content parce que on est dans un pays de
tradition judéo-chrétienne
j'estime que une république laïque qui
ne fait aucun cadeau plus une religion
n'a pas à tolérer le fait que des femmes
se voilent et marche ainsi sur la voie
publique et je rajouterais quelque chose
pour rebondir sur ce que disent errik
radouane faillite il s'est dédouané en
femme voilée pour passer inaperçu en
france
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
d'imaginer de se déguiser en femme
voilée pour passer inaperçu en france ça
veut dire que le mode traditionnel de
notre pays c'est maintenant d'être
voilées pour passer inaperçu c'est un
vrai sujet j'en fais pas un sujet
polémique ni un sujet politique mais
c'est un sujet central alors ramos alors
moi personnellement je suis totalement
contre
donc pour la simple et bonne raison que
j'ai envie de savoir et qui je prends
l'ascenseur et que secundo quand j'ai
posé la question mais papa qui est né
dans les années 60 en tunisie je vais
poser la question est ce que tu avais
déjà vu ça avant ou est ce que c'est un
il m'a répondu que c'est un phénomène
qui est venu beaucoup plus tard ça fait
quelques années que celle exercée mode
mais cette tendance et que ça n'a
absolument rien à voir en vérité avec la
religion donc pour moi je suis contre et
pour moi en plus pour mon dire ce qu'on
dit mes collègues ces questions de
sécurité et ça n'a rien à voir avec la
religion et je pense qu'on peut être
voilés tout simplement être très
heureuse karim zéribi
moi je suis catastrophé qu'on laisse
entendre ce soir que c'est une
prescription qui viendrait du courant je
suis catastrophé parce que y'a rien de
ça dans le coran ça n'a rien à voir ou à
la religion musulmane et on laisse
tendre que la religion musulmane une
fois de plus c'est la négation de la
femme c'est la soumission plein de
fantasmes et derrière conclut
d'alimenter je suis désolé de vous le
dire
moi ce que je regrette à la télé
française c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on
fait on a besoin d'avoir un éclairage
sur la religion musulmane ont fait venir
soit d'aider des gens qui savent pas
s'exprimer en français soit des gens
dire avec du blé qui sont des
clandestins
il n'y a pas un érudit ces français de
confession musulmane qui est invitée
régulièrement à la télé soit je suis
pareil buntschu quitter l'émission vivre
l'histoire on alors dimanche matin qui
est un intellectuel humalex aubry je
vous dis je vous dis qu'aujourd'hui ce
dont manque c'est d'un éclairage de gens
qui ont une connaissance de l'islam
véritable est pas une connaissance de
l'islam par tradition
aujourd'hui ça fait 20 ans que la burqa
le sortie elle est sortie ou en
afghanistan
elle est interdite la fabrication la
fabrication de la burqa au maroc
elle est interdite dans l'extrême nord
du cameroun parce que des attentats elle
est interdite au sénégal elle est
interdite en bulgarie elle était
interdite dans notre cas pas que la
france qui interdit la burqa
allez pas nous faire croire que la
france mène une guerre contre la
religion musulmane au nord de la burqa
ça n'a rien de musulmans à la burqa
alors je veux qu'on le dise haut et fort
à gâteaux pour vous êtes pour bah je
suis pour la liberté individuelle tout
simplement pour dire que je suis toutes
les femmes choisissent de se vêtir ou
non et la liberté de se vêtir et la
liberté de la femme ce n'est pas le
droit d'être à poil c'est le doigt le
droit d'être chansons de s'habiller
comme on veut point barre lausanne 2e
saut je suis contre la diabolisation et
la politisation de ce bout de tissu en
servir des discours nauséabond
effectivement qui met dans le même sac
la religion alors que ça n'a absolument
rien à voir c'est et je suis heureuse
qu'elle que madame vous soyez là ce soir
parce que on a tendance à parler au nom
de ces femmes et à les mettre dans la
catégorie de la victime contraintes
force est soumise
mais pour cette dame c'est un choix mais
une digression
il ya une part de provocation de
certains milieux mais dans la limite de
la loi
ces femmes ces femmes qui s'habillent là
c'est pas pour te provoque et moi il ne
l'est pas du tout mal à l'aise je la
croise dans la rue je suis pas mal à
l'aise et je pense pas c'est bon
grand sens cette date monsieur madame
menace l'ordre public non pas du tout
pas un seul instant je m'attendais la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme a
tranché de rappel deux fois puisqu'elle
a validé l'interdiction du port du voile
intégral sera de retour deux mois ce qui
l a tranché on peut se [ __ ] du comité
des droits de l'homme de l'onu qui n'a
aucun pouvoir gagner à voir mais la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a
tranché par dont le sujet est tranchée
avant la parole à fatiha boyer donc
président de l'association ni [ __ ] ni
soumises qui est farouchement contre que
tim kelly
je voulais dire qu'effectivement
l'accord open des douanes a validé deux
fois que le comité n'a aucun pouvoir je
le répète mais c'est important de le
dire parce que là ça fait un buzz à
willis et l'onu qu'ils aiment et ce avec
un comité là au parloir mais bon bein de
rien est important il ya déjà assez
libre avait dans la mare donc cela top
2010 lorsqu'on a voté cette loi pour
l'anneau dissimulation du visage c'est
une loi il faut la respecter on allons
la réveiller une loi sécuritaire une loi
sécuritaire il faut la respecter la loi
et dernier point
quand j'étais jeune il ya très longtemps
c'était hôtesse de l'air pas l'ordre du
tout oui et je suis allé à jeddah en
arabie saoudite et je vais vous dire on
a été même temps on a à chaque fois
qu'on était hôtesse de l'air
interdiction de sourire aux gens
interdiction de regarder les hommes dans
les yeux il faut s'asseoir dans le fond
dans le bus il ne faut pas porter ne
faut pas sortir comme on est vous jetez
tout les tournées tout les parfums qui
ont de l'alcool fallait les jeux de jack
sock la jeune fille parle et je finis
par l'expérience et j'ai tout respecté
fallait sortir quand on sortait de
l'hôtel à l'otan pour rester je veux
dire moi j'étais stewart je suis allé en
espagne
eh ben j'ai dû manger que de la tomate
mozzarella aussi bien de les sortir avec
une robe tout de suite couvrir les
chevilles et j'avais des collègues
hôtesse de l'air britannique qui était
en prison religieuse non à ce qu'elle
n'avait pas couvertes leurs chevilles
leurs chevilles
donc moi je suis pour le respect des
textes en arabie saoudite et le respect
des textes en france alors fatiha boyer
vous vous êtes contre ni sur donc vous
êtes sous les 10 président de
l'association ni [ __ ] ni soumises en
seine-maritime et vous êtes musulmane
dites nous quelle est votre position
et pourquoi déjà dans un premier temps
moi je trouve que ce débat ne devrait
pas avoir lieu puisque la loi était déjà
voté 2 1 dans un premier temps oui on
voit que mélissa continue à vivre comme
ça et voilà l affaire de l'onudc a
relancé mais ça arrive le côté
artificiel
la loi a été votée normalement ça
devrait pas exister et est ce que je dis
c'est un suicidaire un suicidaire
sociale en ce qui nous concerne ici en
france je ne comprends pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui toutes ces femmes qui
portent la burqa
quel est le bien-être qu'elle leur
apporte et et dans un sens il n'ya aucun
verset dans le coran qui dit que c'est
ce que que ce vêtement et fait partie de
du coran ou religieux y'a rien ça va ça
veut dire que si vous me permettez
madame si vous me permettez
ça veut dire que vous qui portez le la
burqa vous vous êtes plus de religieuses
que moi je le suis et pas du tout alors
mais lifar oui et c'est pas obligatoire
dans les 6m ça je suis d'accord avec
vous mais c'est un choix
et moi je me sens à l'aise comme ça vous
bénisse et vous nous aviez vous êtes
heureuse comme ça oui on y va sans dire
tout ça si vous êtes heureuse quand même
pas comment dire je le respecte je vous
respecte mais on rétrograde la femme
avait dans des pays cyril en effet en
syrie et où dans d'autres pays
les femmes se battent pour pouvoir être
libre ne rien porter sur la taille est
bon en france
malheureusement la loi était votée et
vous portez soit est alors en ces temps
ci est alors un citoyen aimons tous les
deux pour moi c'est la mort je l'avais
entendu deux fortes et madame c'est la
mort vous porter sur vous même je suis
mais je suis à lille c'est mélissa sûr
parce que moi je sinon plus fatiha
laisser la place et là vous répondre
mélissa voyage et moi je suis libre moi
je sais ma liberté
y a personne qui pourra par exemple
comme vous vous pouvez pas me le dire
comment je vais m'habille comme moi je
peux pas le dire ça parce que vous
acceptez que sais je viens de le dire
non il faut pas lire comme ça et on
remettra ça non vous avez pas accepter
ça mon regret en région vie mais mélissa
et karim zéribi vous porter cette burqa
oui on ne la porte pas au nom de l'islam
puisque ça n'est pas dans le coin vous
l'apporté parce que vous avez envie de
la portelli cattoir oui parce que ça n'a
rien à voir avec la billetterie non
c'est un jeu où vous sortez bien comme
ça je me sens un les smiths pourquoi
vous avez été victime de harcèlement
quand vous étiez c'est ça qui vous a
choqué qui vous a fait mal dans cette
décision
non dans ce cas là toutes les femmes qui
sont qui sont harcelés elles devront
être tout comme vous madame
dans le domaine j'avoue je vis je
voudrais essaye de vous comprendre que
je voudrais c'est de vous comprendre
madame tout simplement gears est ma
liberté mais n'y ai dit ça mais il sera
pardon si vous avez été harcelés il ya
des lois de la république qui protège
contre le harcèlement des femmes
notamment dans la rue on a vu des
exemples
pardon mais mais vous n'avez pas à
mettre ce voile pour éviter le
harcèlement vous avez des lois de la
république sa permettent de lutter si
vous nous avait expliqué que vous étiez
un seul état fois que celles concernant
les ché alors confiance à léona palette
mélissa c'est son choix et médias mais
elle accepte de payer la mode on a par
exemple on a retrouvé les images des
deux premières femmes à avoir subi
l'amande et c'est vrai que vous avez
payé donc cette fois la bande en france
regarde les deux femmes ont été
condamnées respectivement à 80 et 120
euros damende une première en france
depuis l'entrée en vigueur de la loi sur
le port du voile intégral le 11 avril
dernier une condamnation qu'elle
attendait avec impatience
très satisfaite enfin on va pouvoir
faire les recours nécessaires pour
saisir la cour européenne et annuler
cette loi qui est une loi de toute façon
illégale la très médiatique et kenza
drider a profité de l'occasion pour
annoncer sa candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
il faudra maintenant qu'elle obtienne
les 500 signatures nécessaires
alors là tu ne réagis c'est en étant
direct assurance btp pour ou contre la
burqa et mélissa guérissent réhabiliter
la cour européenne
déjà qu'à la saisie a donné raison à la
loi française mais il faut le dire
deuxièmement pourquoi ça me gêne et
pourquoi je suis archi vendre parce que
ça ouvre la boîte de pandore à une forme
de confusion entre la burqa et le voile
classique
or le vol classique je suis désolé de le
dire dans les trois religions
monothéistes les femmes croyantes
oui portent le voile peuple porter le
porte et là en l'occurrence je pense que
ça ne doit gêner personne
à partir de ces le libre choix de la
femme les soeurs catholiques porte le
voile
les soeurs juive portent le voile des
sur musulmanes peuvent le porter les
idées circulent à la non la règle même
étaient remisés à paris c'était cette
égalité de noël avait raison cette
équité dans l'analyse on doit le
maintenir en france la france et
libertés
égalité fraternité mais aujourd'hui
c'est un logo au now tendance car on a
tendance avec un sujet de la burqa qui
nous polluent le débat sur une confusion
déjà mérité mais me disais tout à
l'heure à la d une phrase je vous
l'avais pas tout à fait terminé mais
mais vous avez touché le point sensible
en fait pour vous vous placez la loi de
dieu telle que vous l'entendez parce que
c'est pas la loi de l'islam au dessus
des lois de la république et précieuse
c'est ça votre choix
c'est ce que le paradis tous et pas
seulement le harcèlement mais vous avez
commencé une phrase il ya un ciel
d'abord le harcèlement ici assez la loi
du ciel au dessus de la loi de la terre
la loi de la faire c'est d'arrêter mes
chronos étaient porter le niqab et
pourrait finaliser le choix oui mais
c'est la religion telle que vous
l'entendez non non elle te dis que c'est
pas la religion s'est lui fait pas gaffe
salon la religion déjà le très important
c'est le comportement et il faut
distinguer les gens d'après leurs
qualités c'est vrai moi je vois les
choses comme ça tout à fait moi juge pas
les gens comme ça au moins ça ne gêne
pas si je vois quelqu'un soit importé il
femmes elles portent le niqab ou un
porte un short pour moi c'est pareil
ou alors je respecte et si en plus
ancienne petite question pour mélissa
mais il sait ce qu'on vous comprenez que
pour des raisons de sécurité l'a fait
voilà est-ce que ça vous me comprenez
qu'on puisse interdire
voilà le port de la burqa en france pour
des questions de sécurité ce que vous
comprenez ça ou ce qu'on vous dit non
c'est n'importe quoi ça j'ai bien
compris je suis d'accord avec vous mais
je vais les savoirs juste un truc c'est
à dire c'est quelqu'un et la pâle un
cargo lune
la burqa c'est à dire époque elle pourra
pas faire de mal non c'est à dire tous
ces attentats qu'ils ont fait non c'est
juste c'est des gens qui l'inversé n'est
pas vrai non mais non mais l'inversé
n'est pas facile mais il fermait on peut
comprendre qu'on doit voir voilà on
devrait voir se voit le visage de la
personne
on doit pouvoir voir ce qu'elle porte
sur elle il ya le sentiment de
dissimulation est quand même plus fort
quand on sait pas qui on a affaire que
quand on sait à qui on a affaire
pourquoi redoine faïd il a mis une burqa
mais on part que l'on reconnaisse donc
un terroriste il a quand même permis
d'être reconnu
donc je ne dis pas que toutes les femmes
qui posent des burqas son utérus
potentiel je dis que notre pays l'a
décidé
j'ai protégé mais que faire en sorte que
la burqa ne soit pas autorisé pour des
questions de sécurité respecter la loi
mais richard respecter la loi mais me
hassane hourra être une femme une femme
qui porte une bougie pour un short et
elle pourra être non je suis désolé mais
j'aime c'est quand on vous parle c'est
que on est malin il faut que vous
comprenez je me sens mal à l'aise
ça fait peur ça fait pas on nous sommes
pas à l'aise en clair mais les mêmes
heures par jour moi j'adore par jour
voulais me demandais ce que vous dormiez
avec tout à l'heure mais non par jour
vous l'apporté déjà moi je ne porte pas
tous les jours adacore pour vous
conseiller
quand vous sortez pas de chez vous
voulez vous la mettez pas oui tf1 jeu
pour papa parce que je vous le rende pas
même en sortant des fois vous la mettez
pas chez moi chez moi j'ai ma liberté je
mets mes richard j'ai mon billet je vis
une vie normale mais non là d'un cas car
vous portez à l'extérieur tu sais rien
bah quand je sors craint par exemple je
ne porte pas quand j'ai des rendez-vous
administratif ne vient pas d'accord
national
je suis obligé de respecter pour
l'accord visage d'accord alors derrière
vous y'a rachid nekkaz aura alors alors
on va en parler de conclure héros on va
en parler parce que je derrière vous jeu
derrière bouya rachid nekkaz qui est un
homme d'affaires algérien et il s'est
engagé à payer toutes les amendes des
femmes victimes pourquoi il trouve que
tout cela est une injustice imposé par
le port voilà parle par le fort au
faible et au total c'est près de 315
mille euros qu'il aurait dépensé pour
protéger financièrement ces femmes on a
d'ailleurs une vidéo de rachid devant le
centre des finances publiques où il
explique pourquoi vous fait tout ça on
regarde il est juste derrière vous
regardez ça j'ai décidé
millions d'euros de dépenses liberté et
comme je me suis engagé je paierai
toutes les amendes des femmes qui
portent librement le niqab dans la rue
et ce quel que soit l'endroit du monde
où elle vit cette amende est de 172
euros
pourquoi si mes deux billets de 100
euros que je vais remettre à la
trésorerie générale
[Applaudissements]
alors rachid nekkaz vous êtes là vous
êtes merci d'être avec nous d'ailleurs
ce soir d'avoir accepté de venir
alors je pense rachid que autour de la
table vous allez vous faire un petit peu
bousculée j'ai l'habitude alors vous
pourquoi avoir pris cette décision vous
l'expliquer là mais où est ce que pour
pourquoi avoir fait ça alors que comme
on l'a dit si c'est surtout pour des
raisons sécuritaires jours pour pose la
question comme celle que j'ai posée à
mélissa dans des raisons de sécurité
vous pouvez comprendre qu'on peut pas
accepter que des femmes portent la burqa
vous savez j'ai créé un livre qui
s'appelle le voltaire du dic a b que je
vous présente ici et qui explique tous
mes combats depuis 20 ans pour défendre
toutes les formes de liberté à la fois
la liberté de porter le niqab en europe
mais aussi la liberté de ne pas porter
le voile dans les pays musulmans et je
tiens signalé par exemple que lors de la
journée internationale de la femme je me
suis rendu à téhéran en iran le 8 mars
dernier pour faire libérer 29 femmes qui
avait été emprisonné parce qu'elle avait
ôté leur voile dans la rue
donc je défends la liberté de porter le
niqab ou de ne pas porter le voile dans
les sociétés biola attendait racheté il
ya eric naulleau keragis de secrètement
incohérent vous pouvez pas faire la
promotion du niqab et de la burqa ici et
dans les pays où s'est imposé à les
libérer
ces femmes que je vais vous répondre
c'est quoi ton incohérent mais là la
revolver revers n'était pas protestants
il appelle à l'arrivée la dignité de
jean calas qui avait été tué par le
tribunal ça n'a rien à voir le beau de
l'homme vers callas l affaire de la
boutique
non vous êtes associé ça coûtera 2 est
bien sûr rigolo vous êtes un activiste
vous êtes un fouteur de merde et vous
dessaisit lessard le droit de s'inspirer
de voltaire c'est bien çà ou là vous
avez tous les droits appartient à tout
le monde et donc à vous mais simplement
ce que vous faites c'est habillée de
grands mots une stratégie de pompier
pyromane parce que vous refusez indique
m
un militant de votre soeur tout et ça me
dérange beaucoup vous dérange et lettres
double discours et le débat naissant
l'organisation parce que vous savez très
bien qu'en faisant la promotion du niqab
et de la burqa je suis contre le dit
nous envoyer un signe monsieur dallo
envers toutes les femmes qu'il se
donnait son arabie saoudite afin de
porter les gilles simon n'avait
clairement oui et justement j'ai tiré
sur passionnés cab et eric naulleau
par delà la porte s'il ya une loi aux
phrases il faut respecter la loi tout
simplement cessé de l'encourager à
l'essai je vais payer les amendes h et
jam thiam fraigne la loi je suis désolé
je lève dans la loi de changer la courbe
et vous dites c'est pas normal de survie
vous connaissez les règles du fair pay
au rugby
la loi dit la chose suivante si deux
femmes portent le niqab
elle doit payer une amende brawl abois
et d'appliquer la loi en payant cette
amende là et je tiens le dire je tiens à
dire que l'ancien premier ministre avait
fait voter un amendement qui l'appelle
amendement 10 cases et qui m'interdisait
de mes bons de payer les avant de plier
les avants l'écrivain espagnol valu
d'être emprisonné pendant six mois et de
payer une amende de 45000 euros ce à
quoi j'ai répondu que désormais je
n'allais plus payer les amendes mais
j'allais faire un prêt sans intérêt de
181 euros sur 20 ans et c'est ce que
j'appelle le serait pour un monsieur
rachat loi qui est jeune et qui sait
d'après mutations
c'est voltaire où il est pris de
vraiment mais là vraiment vous démérité
de voltaire vous méritez beaucoup de
cantons et voltaire dans notre bouche
6,7 et billy tan universelle des droits
de l'homme rendre les femmes qui ont été
emprisonnés en iran parce que je préfère
des militants des droits de l'homme et
de la femme - doute ce que vous aimez
[Applaudissements]
je vous dis eh bien on voit comment vous
agissez m'arrive
tu as aimé soudan 2013 ses katas jésuite
soudan défendre la jeune à tenir à s'y
risquer d'être flashé sur la place
publique et grâce à mon intervention
libérés sur le terrain
alors quand je respecterai s'il vous
plaît eric revel d'abord que je vais
vous dire avec beaucoup de calme cieux
ce que je ressens je n'ai pas j'ai
entendu parler évidemment de ce que vous
faisiez pour moi vous êtes un
provocateur et vous savez ce qu'il ya de
graves dans votre positionnement c'est
qu'en france on a un contexte politique
extrêmement fragile comme vous le savez
on a un contexte qui attendez attendez
mais joue je vous parle pas de l'algérie
je vous parle de la france même en
france nous avons un contexte
extrêmement fragiles et extrêmement
sensible avec ce type de provocation
permettra de vous dire sans tout à fait
respecté la loi vous attisez ce
sentiment de blocs les uns contre les
autres c'est le but c'est ce que c'est
ce que vous faites et je vais vous dire
'attendez ont déjà permis de provoquer
mais a tenu enfin foudroie termine
simplement en vous disant des choses
vous avez cité voltaire tout à l'heure
il ya un mot à la fin de candide de
voltaire qui est un détournables c'est
l'important c'est de cultiver son jardin
il a dit un cher monsieur chère monsieur
vendrait aviez votre jardin et regarder
les sillons vous êtes en train de tracer
ce qu'ils veulent dire dans un pays
fragmenté socialement et politiquement
comme le nôtre alors ramous jeu alors
pour moi vous êtes un provocateur et un
opportuniste c'est à dire que vous êtes
venus ici je sais faire il a été invité
il a répondu à notre invitation merci
d'ailleurs merci d'être ici
ici on est ouvert on veut discuter et
justement ces phares le débat il par
dialogue qu'on essaie d'améliorer les
choses à la promotion de son livre est
surtout venue justement vous fait ça
juste pour aller dans la provocation et
pour inciter les gens à être hors la loi
mais apparemment vous avez d'argent
vous avez de l'argent à perdre moi j'ai
juste une chose à vous demander y a
moyen jusqu'au au mieux de payer les
frais de
damman de vous payer juste mon brushing
parce que j'ai besoin de temps
j'aimerais j'aimerais parce que là karim
je sens qu'il est en train de
bouillonner
non je ne sais pas que je bouillonne
c'est que je suis tellement en
opposition avec la stratégie de rachid
nekkaz qui consiste effectivement à
créer plus jamais de dire de tension que
d'apaisement dans la société française
nous avons besoin dans notre pays
aujourd'hui d'apaisement on a besoin de
cohésion
on a besoin de partager des valeurs
communes au delà de ce que nous sommes
les uns les autres
qu'on soit juif musulman athée
catholique le sujet il n'est pas là le
sujet c'est est ce qu'on est capable de
vivre ensemble en partageant des valeurs
universelles les valeurs de la
république la laïcité est une chance
pour la france liberté de croire ou de
ne pas croire séparer le politique du
religieux
je veux dire tout le monde d'aujourd'hui
peut s'épanouir dans notre pays pour peu
qu'ils respecteraient règle est là
rachid nekkaz
il incite au non respect des règles et
il est si ton au respect des règles de
qui tu une frange de la population qui
est toujours montrée du doigt
malheureusement et qu'il en france
puisqu'il ne la relève
et puis là je ne peux pas être d'accord
avec ce qu'il fait s'il est totalement
l'opposé de mon idéal de société alors
je juste jamais demandé à mélissa vous
l'initiative de rachid nekkaz
est ce qu'il a payé vos amendes
d'ailleurs vous cette amende et oui vous
avez payé c'est cette amende oui après
le
je commençais à porter le niqab jose
autant balbeli zahoui a après un an et
demi j'ai eu mon premier album j'ai
contacté mission racine kane vous
l'avais contacté
oui qu'est ce que vous pensez de son
initiative ou mao heureusement initiaux
régime 15
donc vous dites quand vous avez des
amendes heureusement y'a rachid nekkaz
oui donc oui c'est un encouragement
geoffrey la loi mais c'est pas grave y'a
quelqu'un qui va payer pour moi monsieur
nekkaz avait après huit années de combat
solitaire parce que j'étais seul dans le
monde à défendre ses fables dans huit
pays
heureusement que l'eau du que j'espère
que vous respectez alors au jeu des
réseaux on va ramener aux autres raison
c'est une honte alors vous en pensez
on va râler parce que ces cartes une
commission des droits de l'homme
exactement qui n'a aucun pouvoir des 100
sur les rapports qu'elle fait aucun à la
fin un rapport effectivement qui
manifestait une méconnaissance de la loi
puisqu'elle n'a pas évoqué la sécurité
intérieure pour laquelle la loi a été a
été posée a été fait et elle n'est venue
que sur le terrain religieux
exor je trouve que la commission des
droits de l'homme fait deux erreurs
un lot mais la question de la sécurité
qui provient d'un souveraineté des
peuples des nations et on est quand même
libre de légiférer comme on l'entend
dans notre pays
et deuxièmement elle fait des amalgames
la commission que joue alors que je
refusais de la valeur vite et ça n'est
pas un signe religieux musulmans alors
jusqu'à karim justement j'aimerais me
posez la question à monsieur des quatre
vous qu'est ce que vous dites quand on
vous dit que c'est pour la sécurité
n'est quà savez c'est un argument nancy
fallacieux arrêté je vous précise la
circulaire guéant que prévoit-elle elle
prévoit que toutes les femmes qui
portent le niqab doivent s'identifier
c'est-à-dire doivent lever le voile pour
qu'un agent de police puissent vérifier
son identité et les femmes qui portent
le niqab sont totalement d'accord pour
respecter cette circulaire guéant et je
ne comprends pas pourquoi il y ait de
l'eau et de boucliers
m je te rappeler c'est de finir et
qu'elle est quasiment des émeutes parce
qu'on voulait bien sûr hôtel
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
a validé à l'interdiction du jëf rnr
monsieur des cases
je trouvais moins ce qu'a dit la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme balles
a dit la chose suivante elle a accepté
de valider l'interdiction du niqab en
france et en belgique
à condition que la peine soit
proportionné aux délits c'est à dire en
l'occurrence se délite et une amende de
172 euros
mais elle refuserait de valider cette
interdiction
si l'appel n'était pas proportionnée je
vous donne un exemple en suisse
sachant que j'allais payer les amendes
ils ont prévu dans le canton du tessin
une amende à 9200 euros
je me suis rendu sur place et j'ai
remercié la suisse d'avoir voté cette
loi et je leur ai dit que grâce à vous
j'allais gagner à la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et bien figurez vous
que depuis 2016 le canton du tessin n'a
jamais dressé une à bord de 9 bus 200
euros car il savait que j'allais gagner
alors lors d'un recours auprès de la
cour européenne des droits de la la la
cdc des affaires juridiques alors
j'aimerais avoir l'avis de fatiha boyer
donc je rappelle que c'est la présidente
de l'association ni [ __ ] ni soumises en
seine-maritime ému et vous êtes
musulmane qu'est ce que vous pensez vous
de l'initiative de monsieur des cas je
suis contre et si la provocation total
mais à 1000% monsieur est d'autant plus
que vous êtes vous vous présentez pour
plus tard prochainement dans les
élections présidentielles en algérie
alors je pense que oui oui oui alors
c'est une information
mais si ces sept milliardaires ou
quelqu'un vous finances s'est fait
piquer mes finances je voudrais vous
avez ce graphe à la france où j'ai pu
développer des activités dans
l'immobilier et aujourd'hui je suis très
fier d'avoir une indépendance financière
donc vous financez vous fait percer vous
même monsieur oui je le fais non plus ah
oui tu peux te permet d'appliquer sur le
terrain les principes de liberté
d'égalité et de fraternité fait ça coûte
cher la présidence à l'école de la
république et à la farb à 12 est ce que
dit le coran à l'aise et musulmans
respecter la loi
les lois du pays dans lequel vous vivez
alors ce n'est pas justement alors on va
en barrois
c'est vrai aujourd'hui on est en direct
aux balances ton poste pour ou contre la
burqa et on est allé en caméra cachée on
envoyait des personnes en burqa dans la
rue c'est en deux fois regardé première
fois les envoyer dans la rue regardez ce
qui s'est passé
alors pour l'instant voyez tout tout se
passe bien il ya là policiers passent
dans wii elle n'a pas été arrêté et ça
se passe en deux temps regarder dans un
deuxième temps ce qui se passe
[Musique]
alors figurez vous que cette jeune fille
donc a été amené au commissariat
donc on va voir la demande on espère que
vous la paire et pour nous non mais
voilà et donc c'est vrai que cette jeune
fille dont il a été transféré au
commissariat vous voyez elle s'est très
vite fait arrêter vous donc vous dès que
vous faites vous pouvez pas faire 20
mètres dans la rue mélissa votre vie est
un enfer on pouvait pas faire 20 mètres
dans la rue bah oui oui on n'est pas
tranquille
oui mais donc parce qu'au début de
l'interview vous me disiez que vous
étiez heureuse non je suis heureuse
parce que je porte le niqab mais je suis
embêté avec les policiers dans la rue
oui mais vous rendez compte l'avis que
vous avez moi je dis c'est voilà parce
que vous dites vous êtes heureux vous
rendez compte vous êtes condamnés à
rester tout à fait comme ça il ya des
tas de quartiers de paris où il est hors
de question d'arrêter une femme en burqa
ou un niqab parce que ce sera une émeute
immédiate est que les policiers veulent
pas la balle a provoqué donc je sais pas
où ça a été pris c'était une gare ou
woodstock austruy est pas loin d'y
saint-louis ben ya des quartiers où
c'est pas possible et ce alors justement
mélissa vous habitez ou dans quel
quartier vous pouvez nous dire vous
habite à paris vous habitez paris paris
d'accord mais voilà et quand vous pouvez
faire vous pouvez sortir de votre
quartier faire les courses tout ça ou
pas du tout oui j'ai sont d'accord et ça
c'est pour la généralement ça se passe
et vous n'avez été que ça se passe bien
on dirait que je suis
plus embêté de questions d'accord les
ouïes par les personnes âgées et à un
peu peur c'est ça bernard laporte savoir
du du jour au lendemain vous avez porté
le voile oui qu'est-ce qui a fait comme
matin vous êtes dit aujourd'hui moi je
vais le porter c'est un changement avait
envie depuis longtemps c'est un truc qui
vous trotter dans la tête
oui vous êtes vous êtes mariés non
d'accord vous êtes célibataire si les
batteurs et j'ai personnes de ma famille
qui vivre en france adacore dont vous
êtes seul en france
oui d'accord famille vivait ou en
algérie
d'accord vous poser une dernière clair
nous avancions je veux pas vous amener
n'a même pas le temps de ne pas vous
embêter parce que j'ai le sentiment que
vous le portez un coup vous le portez
pas douter d'eux car ils simplement on
sait même pas on peut même temps non
mais ça mérite wallon c'est la plus
basse que vous avez vous n'avez pas le
sentiment qu à la communauté musulmane
voulu fait du mal oui ou non elle dit
non pas alors on vous dit non
s'il vous plaît mélissa est facile en
train de parler comme ça c'est ça qui me
fait mal parce que nous on demanderait
on demande la paix ont fait rien quand
on ne fait pas de mal si on va continuer
sur ce débat parce que vous réagissez
énormément à ce débat sur la burqa et
hashtag balances ton post bien sûr c'est
ce qu'on dit dans l'oreille merci merci
madame mais juste ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que la france a été le
premier à interdire mais ensuite ça a
été la bulgarie la belgique les pays bas
ont interdit la burqa en suisse deux
cantons interdisent et aux etats unis
pas d'interdiction puisque selon des
propos de donald trump en 2015 ce serait
même pratique pour les femmes pour ne
pas avoir à se maquiller regardez cette
voie
ouais bon appétit
[Applaudissements]
alors ça c'était un extrait du stand-up
donald trump au caveau de la huchette
melania mais c'est fou on croirait
vraiment que c'est un stand up et ce
n'est pas des vannes c'est incroyable
parce que c'est vrai que tout le monde
rigole d'ailleurs dans l'assemblée alors
juste on va revenir à tuer mais c'est
vrai que la france a été le premier pays
à interdire
rachid nekkaz si vous nous rejoignez et
voilà est un homme d'affaires algérien
qui lui s'est engagé à payer toutes les
amendes des victimes
on l'a vu on a vu cette vidéo il le dit
devant le centre des finances publiques
ont également une vidéo de rachid nekkaz
qui est en partance pour régler une
amende avec nadine morano qui essaye de
faire barrage
regardez et sa suite est une image qui
avait beaucoup beaucoup tourné regarde
vous utilisez une faille de cette loi
pour inciter à violer la loi française
qui interdit de porter le voile intégral
je ne fais qu'appliquer la loi
ces personnes reçoivent une amende je ne
fais que les pays à leur place absolue
alors oui eric ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que mélissa et les autres femmes en
burqa en réalité sont les victimes de
monsieur nekkaz
on en parlait pendant l'interruption
gens parler directement avec l'intéressé
monsieur mais casse favorise une double
exclusion de ces femmes il favorise une
première exclusion l'exclusion du champ
public parce qu'une femme qui se
baladent en burqa attire l'attention
elle est immédiatement mise à part je
vois dans mon quartier où ça arrive
d'avoir des femmes en burqa et il
favorise le réclusion aux yeux de la loi
deux fois il les met en marge de la
société et ils appellent ça une
tentative d'émancipation de la femme et
il fait ça au nom de la liberté
excuse moi c'est complètement incohérent
monsieur nekkaz est un aventurier
idéologique je pense qu'il a une seule
cause une seule cause lui tient à coeur
c'est la sienne de faire sa promotion et
de faire parler de lui sur le dos des
femmes en burqa je trouve ça lamentable
et aux gens mais conviennent aussi sur
la sur les propos de fatiha et 2005 mais
juste répondait monsieur nekkaz a savez
la sorbonne m'a appris à respecter les
opinions des uns et des autres je
respecte le conseil d'état français
c'est la plus haute autorité
administrative en france il y à 300
spécialistes du droit et en 2009 et en
2010 à deux reprises le conseil d'état a
émis 1 de la vie il a dit au
gouvernement déchu sarkozy oui pour
interdire le niqab dans tous les espaces
publics fermés comme les banques les
écoles les centres commerciaux les
tribunaux les hôpitaux mais on ne peut
pas interdire le niqab dans la rue car
dixit loïc site cela ne reposerait pas
sur des fondements juridiques suisses
olias déchets de l'eau est ce que
aujourd'hui le lot est ce que
aujourd'hui en octobre 2018 il est légal
ou illégal de se promener en burqa dans
la rue en france oui ou non je vous
demande pas d'argent mais de le faire je
réponds aujourd'hui c'est illégal de
payer les messieurs c'est pas légal de
payer les amendes aux sept bateaux
voiliers d'amande c'est qu'on est hors
la loi donc c'est sa culture et c'est
maintenant le jeu je vous réponds arrivé
je paie d avance dans huit pays dans
huit pays européens la suisse d'avoir
commis une infraction détaille marc
comment ces contrées comme une
infraction quand on fait une amende non
je n'ai qu'à ce dont on ignore la vie la
mort le paiement de la bande à une
infraction pouvait pas dire si c'est le
droit à banon le paiement de l'amendé
adultes alors non mais je vous dis je
vous dis des bêtises
non mais non ça veut dire n'importe quel
spécialiste en droit le paiement d'une
amende adule l'infraction lequel c'est
le réseau pour laquelle lorsqu'on paie
abandon peut plus faire de recoudre
dessus et eric revel bon mois on vient
de voir une vidéo là où vous êtes et je
retire pas le terme des gens payés tout
à l'heure dans la provocation absolue g
pardonnez moi j'ai pardonné moi j'ai
pardonné moi monsieur
il vous en sait un peu petite question à
vous poser et imposer de suite de quoi
on vous voit sur la vidéo avec un
drapeau algérien autour du cou
vous avez expliqué tout à l'heure que
vous aviez fait fortune que vous
pourriez payer les amendes grâce à ce
pays généreux dans l'immobilier qui
s'appelle la france
quel besoin vous avez d'arborer le
drapeau algérien autour du cou alors que
vous avez en face de vous une
représentante politique nationale qu'on
aime ou qu'on n'aime pas c'est pas le
sujet j'étais en france et vous mettez
le drapeau algérien pourquoi monsieur je
vais vous répondre de chirurgie c'est
très simple en 2013 j'ai renoncé à ma
nationalité française aujourd'hui je
suis exclusivement algérien bas d'abord
à grasse après la fortune jeux jeux
réponse à cette question s'est amusé à
critiquer ma citoyenneté algérienne sur
les réseaux sociaux lorsqu'elle a appris
que j'allais veut dire payer une amende
dans sa ville dans son fief à toul et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
souhaité veut dire avec beau drapeau
algérien qu'elle avait dénigré
ah si injustement alors alors je gagnais
le 2 le débat de ce soir plusieurs
mérites a rappelé qu'à une loi dans
notre pays qui interdit la burqa
en somme c'est quand même bien de le
faire 2 que ce n'est pas une
prescription émanant de la région
musulmane
je suis désolé mais les millions de
français qui peuvent ne pas connaître ne
pas comprendre la région musulmane ont
besoin de savoir que ce n'est pas une
prescription de la religion musulmane
et troisièmement moi je lui dis ce qui
nous regarde si vous êtes musulman ne
pratiquez pas votre religion en fonction
de ce qu'on va vous dire pratiquer votre
religion en allant chercher le savoir il
ya des livres il ya de la connaissance
acquérir cantons pratiquent une religion
c'est pas lundis je fais ça mardi je
fais autre chose et je pense que le
problème de la communauté musulmane
c'est cette absence de travail
intellectuel de recherche de
connaissances d'appréciation du chèque
haussier dans lequel on vit échec dans
lequel on biffe accompagnons non mais
oui mais s'ils n'avaient pas généraliser
car je veux dire pourquoi il n'ya pas de
clergé un islam cyril vous ne savez
peut-être pas non serre que chacun peut
se déterminer imams ça représente un
vrai problème
mais bon je dis moi je dis la dia neeson
des lumières cet islam des lumières
il faut aujourd'hui qu'on aille le
chercher aussi dans les livres salue
marie zekri l'exercice
on va on va clôturer avec doc gynéco oui
et comme vous pouvez le voir il porte la
burqa cyrille louis pour pour et puis
vous vous tous et oui pour les parlers
bien ford pour les croyants la justice
divine c'est pas la même que celle des
hommes et quelles que soient les nations
où elle est les lois sont appliquées
pour eux dieu et il pardonner il a des
façons de voir les choses différemment
merci ben voilà